hi there Steve coffin here today you
know two days from now I am flying off
to Montreal for the long Fest festival
day long and of course this is one of a
number of conferences held around the
world originally called polyglot
conferences or sometimes called polyglot
gatherings the one in Montreal is this
coming weekend it's not too late to in
you know register if you use Steve
uppercase lowercase doesn't matter as
your access code you'll get a discount
and there's one in Fukuoka Japan in
October that I'm going to and it's all
part of this whole polyglot phenomenon
more and more people are speaking more
and more languages and they are
communicating with each other through
the internet through other means at
these conferences you know in Montreal
there's a gathering of this group called
mundo lingo that exists in many places
where lots of people arrive at this cafe
they're given flags for each of the
languages that they speak and then you
just wander around talking to people in
whatever language you see on their tag
and some people have ten languages or
more more flags and it's just a
wonderful evening and you go from person
to person speaking different languages
and and you know and any one of these
gatherings like The Gathering in
Montreal there's gonna be 500 or so
people all of whom speak two three four
eight and languages these are not all
people who have quote a special talent
for languages these are not people who
sat through language class who went to
university to learn languages
necessarily they might have done those
things but not all five 600 of them and
and it's what has happened is that it's
become so much easier to learn languages
access like you know Netflix I'm having
a wonderful time with my Turkish
watching this cereal in the evening with
my wife and then downloading the try
stripped and of course I can't keep up
to where we are in the TV you know
watching the different episodes but I'm
getting a better and better sense of how
the language is used and it's a
wonderful feeling to to start being
absorbed into the language then I pick
away at the words using our you know our
web browser extension and and that's
only one example you know there's my
Turkish tutors on I talk either's I can
look up any grammar term I want the old
idea that you sat in the classroom and
that the teacher was the source of the
language the teacher decided what you
had learned the teacher explained the
language the teacher told you not to go
ahead because the teacher wanted you to
be there
the teacher tried to force you to speak
before you were ready the teacher
corrected you when you got something
wrong none of that is necessary it's a
new world
it's the polyglot world we are entering
that golden age of multiple language
learning polyglots and that's a little
bit of what I'm gonna talk about in
Montreal and again in Japan and tomorrow
I think I'll do a video in Japanese and
I will talk up the polyglot gathering in
Fukuoka which I think is October 18th to
20th where any of you who live in Japan
hopefully will attend or live in Asia or
like the travel will also show up there
so we are in entering the Golden Age of
polyglot ISM multilingualism and it's
only going to get better and I hope to
see some of you in Montreal bye for now
you